[Applause]
happy super duper monday everybody
thanks to the supply chain crisis
there's been a shortage of everything
but idiots
yeah for some reason the chain that
supplies lying morons is flowing more
smoothly than the flatulence out of
biden's butt
i should stop making those jokes
but i'm not
that's one area where biden's excelled
at job creation
fact is the media is impervious to any
of the challenges and strug struggles a
regular americans face largely because
those in the media make a lot of money
and they're stupid
for some reason those things go together
like dating apps and stds
also unlike the media regular americans
get fired for waving their weenies in
the workplace
at least that's how i got fired from
burger king
but it's that combination of wealth
caused arrogance and stupidity that
results in all kinds of laughable
analysis the kind that would give the
best alf episode a run for its money
like over at nbc stephanie rule keeps
trotting out the same old line to defend
joe biden tell us the dirty little
secret steph
the dirty little secret here willie
while nobody likes to pay more on
average we have the money to do so
household savings hit a record high over
the pandemic we didn't really have
anywhere to go out and spend
she called me willie
that's so much a secret as it is
something a person with a major head
injury would say a secret would be how
any of you keep your jobs if she were
any more of a dumbbell chris cuomo would
be curling her
yeah they're still saying that inflation
isn't bad because the government printed
all this money and gave it to you to
spend which of course drives up prices
since money becomes cheaper once you
print more of it dems know the economy
about as well as i know the layout of
the big and tall men's store
with their logic
why doesn't the government just print a
trillion dollar bill for everyone
we're all rich baby but you couldn't
come up with anything dumber oh wait
what's tiffany cross going to say about
truck drivers
this is again an industry populated
by a lot of white men over the age of 55
this group of people overwhelmingly
voted for trump um some people have
talked about you know aggressive truck
drivers uh cutting them off or not being
helpful um so obviously the more
populated it is with people of color i
think you'll see less of that
excellent work there tiffany
take the supply chain crisis and turn it
into a mush of racism sexism trump and
rude driving
all she left out was the p-tape
or in the case of our nation's truckers
a pea bottle
they pee in a bottle because they don't
want to stop thank you tyrus it's okay
if they don't get it a truck but really
that was a good joke it was great thank
you but underlying all the criticism is
a not-so-subtle mockery of everyday
concerns take captain neck fat over at
cnn
see that's funny make fun of him
captain neck fat at the net [ __ ] yeah
he's taking a much-needed break after
devouring a gingerbread house made of
pork
he tweeted this picture of a supermarket
aisle filled with milk and he wrote the
supply chain she exclaims looking for
milk for a two-year-old look at this
amazing overflowing abundance he
responds
meanwhile the ted the average 10 year
old from iowa can tell him most milk is
produced locally and is not imported but
our portly prevaricator thinks we get
all of our two percent low-fat dairy
from the only finest regions in france
he may have also said let them eat cake
but that's what his answer is to
everything
i'm surprised he didn't include a
picture of a woman breastfeeding and
right see no supply chain delay there
but brian hosts a dying show called
ironically reliable sources which is yet
to admit that the four-year narrative
they pushed on russian collusion was as
real as a stripper's boobs
once again his network relies on
americans forgetfulness when it comes to
the repetitive deceptions and the damage
it did to so many institutions including
and especially the media but hey it's
not like the media gets anything right
am i right
tonight on the chess news network
[Music]
david brooks here at the chess news
network we're in new york city where
everything's fine inflation's great and
if you don't like it too bad
here's a happy citizen right now what
happened you took my bag ah so you're
enjoying the release of any stress from
that bag pulling on my wallet and car
keys were in there so less driving
you're looking forward to reducing your
carbon footprint i'm looking forward to
buying lunch i can't eat today now
intermittent fasting more popular than
ever back to ukraine
excellent acting
so as they continue to push lies like a
farmer pushes a wheelbarrow full of
manure
they call on their own industry to stop
treating republicans as normal
i think you also have to have some new
ground rules for the media i think they
have to stop treating republicans like
normal politicians they're not normal
politicians this is not normal conduct
this is a party that spends its entire
time cooking up these ridiculous
cultural memes
fanning violence
and coming up with uh outright lies
is that woody allen in a wig
paul geez
apologies mr allen
[Applause]
jennifer rubin though calling out anyone
is abnormal that's like andrew cuomo
telling a tsa agent to keep your hands
to yourself
of course ruben's the sellout they quote
whenever they want to bash conservatives
the kind of republican who makes mitt
romney look like abe lincoln jennifer
rubin is so bad even the reuben sandwich
is considering changing its name to
something less embarrassing like burger
but it's not surprising the media's
brazen defense of joe's downfall
is as irrational as the attacks on trump
but in reverse
perhaps they know what a mistake they
made trading peace and prosperity in
exchange for fewer mean tweets
was it worth less food on the table was
it worth shortages and four dollar gas
was it worth giving china such a boost
that even our allies are taking mandarin
lessons
now they got what they wanted in all its
misery and they pretend that you deserve
it too good luck with that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else